bonjour marc antoine jamet merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
alors on l'a dire le groupe lvmh a
promis de fournir des milliers des
millions de masques à la france une
opération montée très rapidement
expliquez nous comment marche cette
livraison de masques à l'état d'avoir
les choses sont simples 40 millions de
masques 10 millions qu'il fallait
bloquer immédiatement soit ça nous
n'aurions pas eu la commande et c'est
bernard arnault qu'il avançait il y
attenant 6 millions d'euros soit table
que nous paierons directement et puis
pour le reste on avance à l'état nous
acheminons nous livrons nous gérons en
utilisant un réseau commercial qui est
ancien de lvmh en chine puisque nous
avons 24 mille salariés et ordinaire ils
achètent des produits en france comment
nous les produisons une légende en chine
nous avons inversé c'est à dire que nous
achetons en chine pour ramener en france
rapporté en france des produits médicaux
en effet à la fois des respirateurs et
des masques et c'est comme ça que nous
cherchons à passer des contrats avec les
grandes entreprises parce qu on fabrique
on a dit un l'opération s'est monté
assez rapidement quelles ont été les
consignes de votre direction
et comment vous vous êtes organisé
justement pour pour cette grande
opération la chose facile et plus facile
dans un groupe familial ses claviers la
décision appartient à une seule personne
interne à redon qui nous a également
mobilisé comme il l'avait fait pour le
gel en trois jours on a été capable de
livrer l'ap-hp et de continuer par 50
tonnes produites chaque semaine un livre
et un grand nombre d'institutions qui en
ont besoin hôpitaux mais également
prêché de police aux compagnies
aériennes une grande distribution hélas
est à même de la même manière il nous a
dit trouver des basketball acheteurs se
sont répandus mais la différence avec
d'autres peut-être c'est que nos
acheteurs eux vont dans les usines sont
dans des camions conduisent ou à fumer
nous accompagnent les produits jusqu'à
l'aéroport et c'est ça qui est notre
sens probablement s'était pas dû trouver
portes closes ou des choses plus
compliquées
nous avons un sujet qui est le suivi de
notre réseau sur place elle a encore une
direction qui est clair qui est simple
et d'instruction bernard arnault une
cellule qui est une cellule de se tester
rapidité qui marche pour d'autres
produits normalement et il sur place un
réseau qui est un réseau de terrain et
de proximité un réseau de connaissances
alors des décisions
anti arrive donc de chine chargé de de
matériel médical est ce que tout se
passe bien aujourd'hui dans ces
opérations
et est ce que vous arrivez toujours à
trouver les avions nécessaires pour
rapatrier tout ce matériel en france
trouvez les avions nous y arrivons avec
nos partenaires geodis où l'état ou
bolloré logistics est difficile c'est
compliqué la donne une chose rare bill
nous arrivons à trouver c'est clair sur
place
il ya un grand nombre d'acheteurs
d'acheteurs européens d'acheteurs
mondiaux il y a le gouvernement chinois
qui veut jouer son propre rôle il ya
aussi des entreprises qui sont plus
compliquées que d'autres et c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué très
difficile mais la situation est très
compliquée et très difficiles sont en
crise et donc il est normal que les
choses soient compliquées parce qu'il
faut aller plus vite parce que les
contrats doivent être rédigées plus
simplement parce que parfois c'est vrai
il ya plusieurs personnes qui veulent
acheter les mêmes cargaison mais je
crois que c'est assez générales et et
peu à peu les choses rentrent dans
l'ordre je crois plus belle en chinois
cherchent à faire attention lui aussi a
augmenté à diriger à orienter bonne
chose plutôt que de laisser quelque
chose qui serait un peu compliqué qui
s'organiserait avec de multiples
acheteurs et des vendeurs qui ne
seraient pas toujours scrupuleux les
choses s'arrangent
alors sur notre antenne lundi soir le
président du conseil régional de la
région paca évoquait plusieurs problèmes
avec l expédition de ces masques en
chine notamment une équipe américaine
qui aurait payé en cash une cargaison a
prévu pour la france est détournée donc
au dernier moment vers les états unis
est-ce que vous avez rencontré ce genre
de difficultés et est ce que ce genre de
pratique vous étonne elle ne m'étonne
pas je voulais dit nous sommes dans une
situation de crise est vrai qu'il ya des
acheteurs de tous les pays européens de
tous les pays touchés par la crise donc
ce qui va au delà de l'europe que chacun
cherche à faire valoir l'urgence est la
priorité de son gouvernement parfois des
moyens qui sont discutables vous les
citer mais sur les situations nous avons
vu à plusieurs reprises auger
cherchons-nous belle lvmh sur les
instructions bernard arnault à être à la
fois transparent et être parfaitement je
dirais réglo c'est à dire nous ne
commettons évidemment aucune de ces
maladresses ou choses désagréables nous
arrivons nous passons des contrats et je
crois qu'à partir du moment où on est
clair avec son acheteur et son vendeur
les choses se passent bien mais c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué il ya plein
d'acheteurs dans tous les sens il ya
plein d'entreprises qui naissent
qu'ils se mettent à produire ces
produits qui sont très demandés du coup
ça devient un peu le far west où la loi
de la jungle mais les choses n'ont pas
rentré dans l'ordre grâce au
gouvernement chinois qui cherchent à
faire attention et vérifier que sa
respectabilité et évidemment garantie
merci beaucoup marc antoine jamet
d'avoir été avec nous ce midi sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général du groupe lvmh